COLT MCANLIS: Hello everyone.
Oh, come on guys.
Look up from your pixels.
Let's try this again.
Hello everyone.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
COLT MCANLIS: All right.
That's the type of pre-lunch
enthusiasm I
would expect on a Thursday.
I can't see all of your
hangovers, that's good.
All right, hello everyone.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
I'm a developer advocate at
Google working on Chrome.
And joining me today is the
amazingly talented Grace
Kloba, who happens to be
the technical lead
on Chrome for Android.
So all of the cool Chrome on
mobile questions can go to her
after the talk.
But if you have questions
about my shirt,
that come to me.
What we're here today to talk
to you about is how to
supercharge your websites, both
on mobile and on desktop,
with the help of using the
GPU and a lot of amazing
intrinsics that we've put
inside of Chrome.
Quick show of hands, how many
of you attended the Jank
Busters talk yesterday?
Awesome, that's a good set.
That's a good set.
You can view the content that
we're going to talk about
today as a pairing of what Nat
talked about yesterday.
Today we're going to talk about
how to use the GPU to
get awesome stuff done.
Now before we begin, I want
to point you all to this
beautiful perfmatters hashtag.
Quick show of hands, how many
of you have seen this on the
interwebs so far?
You all are my favorite
people.
Hugs for everyone after that.
Come find me later.
If you see something today
that inspires you, some
statistic you didn't know, or
some cool technique that you
haven't heard of before, please
feel free to go to your
social media outlet
of choice and use
the perfmatters hashtag.
Spread the word.
Spread the love.
That's what we're all here
at Google to do.
I'll quit wasting time
at this point.
Let's dig into it.
Before we can talk about how the
GPU is used to supercharge
your website into awesome town,
we first need to start
with a little bit of history so
that you can understand how
Chrome actually draws
your web page.
It all starts at the top with
a very complex series of
algorithms known as software
rasterization.
Effectively, this suite of
tools, or algorithms and
computation, is responsible
for taking a high-order
primitive, like this beautiful
little glyph we have here,
subdividing it into
boundary pixels.
And then finally, adding
color to it and
pushing it to your screen.
So we can actually subdivide it,
add some color to it, and
you can see that this is
programmer art, so, of course,
my at symbol is very,
very pixelated.
Now Chrome will use this
concept of software
rasterization as your
page is loaded.
Chrome loads your page.
It'll actually go through and
software rasterize everything
you see, so all of the glyphs
that you see, your images, the
small text, the lines on the
screen, the borders, the
rounded edges, the
drop shadows.
This is all being pushed
through the software
rasterization path into
a single large bitmap.
And then what happens is, as you
scroll, what Chrome will
do is it'll do the smart thing
and it'll actually go through
a series of memory copy
operations and effectively
take all of those lines, the
scan lines in the bitmap, and
mem copy them to a position
that's higher in the bitmap.
And then it'll go back through
and only software rasterize
what hasn't been seen
on the page.
This, of course, means
that Chrome is
doing the smart thing.
It's not spending all of its
time software rasterizing divs
as they're positioned
on the page.
It's only updating what is
new and what is awesome.
GRACE KLOBA: So it's
2013, right?
Most of the sites has animation,
transition, to make
it look good.
So what is animation?
It's essentially bits update
to the screen constantly to
make it feel like a movie.
So let's take a look
at this example.
We have this rubber duck
animated through the river to
the other side.
So for every frame, we
have to move the
duck to a new location.
This means for every frame, we
have to paint to the duck in
the new location with
a new background.
And then go back to where
the duck used to be and
then erase the duck.
And [INAUDIBLE]
just clean background.
Essentially, for every
frame, we have to
paint these two regions.
And there's a new trend,
the retina display.
So it makes the display look
pretty because it doubles the
screen resolution, which
quadruples the number of the
pixels pushed onto the screen.
So Colt mentioned earlier during
the scrolling for every
frame we do a mem copy.
That's not free.
It's even not cheap with the
retina display because we're
pushing quadruple number of the
pixel to the screen while
the memory bus speed
hasn't caught up.
And in the animation case, for
every frame we have to paint
the two regions.
So now that region is quadruple
the size, which
means a much longer
paint times.
So if we look at the chart,
the number keep going up.
It's not coming down anytime
soon, at least I was not told.
So Colt, what do we do?
COLT MCANLIS: Well, you see,
because these things keep
getting larger and larger and
larger, we have to take
advantage of the hardware that's
resident on the system.
So everyone should have
pixels by now.
I see most of you
typing on them.
And everyone should have one
of these beautiful little
phones in your pocket as well.
All of these contain one common
element, is they have a
new piece of hardware-- well,
an old piece of hardware
really-- called a graphics
processing unit, or a GPU.
Now, GPUs were actually created
in the mid to late
'90s to effectively help with
a concept of software
rasterization needed for
games and boring
stuff like CAD software.
Effectively, architects came
together and created dedicated
hardware to do software
rasterization.
And then we started calling
it hardware
rasterization after that.
These GPUs super excel at doing
software rasterization.
They are amazingly capable
to push pixels
around on the screen.
They do it better than anything
else we have out on
the market today.
So the cool thing is that if the
GPU is actually the best
at moving pixels and doing
software rasterization, the
question for Chrome is, how do
we utilize this piece of
hardware to make your webpages
render faster?
Now, as we already talked about,
you can look at our
upload diagram in a hierarchical
view of this.
So we start with our
page layout.
And that, of course, is
rasterized by the CPU.
Then every frame that you make
small updates, the CPU is
responsible for updating
and presenting those
pixels to the screen.
Now this means that there's a
lot of work going on in the
CPU as you do small scrolls,
big scrolls, and then
animations over the page.
Because of the fact of that
the GPU is actually really
good at pushing pixels, it makes
sense then that we can
insert the GPU between the CPU
and the actual monitor.
So this means that the CPU can
do a single upload the GPU and
allow the GPU to handle
finalized positioning on the
screen on your behalf.
This reduces the overall amount
of CPU work that has to
be done rendering your
pages a lot faster.
Clicky.
Ah, there we go.
GRACE KLOBA: So recalling the
CPU mode, we allocate one big
bitmap to cover the entire
visible regions.
In the GPU mode, we divided the
page into smaller tiles.
And each tile is cached in the
GPU memory as a texture.
So let's reexamine the case
where we scroll the page.
When the page is first loaded,
we allocate enough number of
the tiles to cover the
visible areas.
And then when the page is
scrolling down, some of the
tiles from the previous frame
are still visible.
But they are drawn in a
different position relative to
the window of the screen.
So one key difference
here is we can't
read off the mem copy.
So retina display, nice and
we are fine with it.
Similar as a software rendering
mode, there will be
new content to show.
And then we just allocate the
new tiles, render them in the
CPU, and upload them to
the GPU textures.
Some of the old tiles from
the previous frame
now they are invisible.
If there's enough GPU memory,
we leave them in the cache.
So if the page is scrolling up,
they will be visible and
we have them right away.
There's no need to
do a CPU paint.
If you continue scrolling down,
at some point we're
going to run out
of GPU memory.
What happens is we go back to
the oldest tiles, which user
hasn't seen for a while,
and we recycle them.
This means if those tiles will
be visible again, we have to
go back to the CPU to paint them
and upload them to the
GPU texture.
So the amount of the GPU memory
available is really
device dependent.
The goal for us is to keep as
much as possible in the GPU
memory, so when user interacting
with a page, we
can avoid going to
the CPU to paint.
Before we move on to the next
topic, I want to mention,
Chrome can also do
pre-painting.
So earlier, I mentioned when the
page is the first loaded
Chrome allocates enough tiles
for the visible areas.
During the idle cycle, we
proactively paint the area
just outside of the
visible region.
And this prediction also
is gesture aware.
So for example, if you're
scrolling down a page, the
pre-paint will pre-paint the
area below the current visible
area because that's the
direction going.
COLT MCANLIS: So this is really
cool for scrolling, but
it actually puts us in a little
bit of a bind when we
start talking about
the same duck
animation as we saw before.
By the way, ducks should be
the new animation thing in
presentations, in my
personal opinion.
I'm going to start
this movement.
Too many people put cats
in their slides.
I really think ducks are ready
for a comeback, especially if
you've ever been bitten
by a duck.
Actually it hurts a lot.
Anyhow, as we have the duck--
that's my aside, right?
We got time.
We got plenty of time.
Story time with Colt.
You can hashtag that.
That'll be fun.
Anyhow, as the duck is actually
flowing across the
pond here, we run
into a problem.
Where before, in the software
mode, we would actually
rasterize the regions that
were dirtied by the duck
moving around, we now actually
have to rasterize more pixels
because we have to redraw
the entire tile that's
touched by the duck.
So as you can see here, we have
the duck moving from a
one by two over to
a two by two.
We have to redo all of
those tiles at once.
So we're touching a lot more
pixels during our animation.
So this means the GPU tiles
can actually get us
into a bit of a bind.
Clicky.
Hashtag clicky.
There you go.
Can you do it for me?
I think we just broke
the internet.
Anyone?
Can anyone fix the internet?
You are all tweeting
right now.
That's the problem.
You are all going
and tweeting.
You're hashtagging.
AUDIENCE: Don't you
mean Google+?
COLT MCANLIS: Google+'ing,
thank you.
Actually, thank you for that.
OK.
I can reboot it.
That might work.
Maybe I should install Vista.
That'll actually help too.
Or did we freeze?
I'm going to do a song
and dance while he
tries to fix this.
What do you want on here?
AUDIENCE: What's that?
COLT MCANLIS: What do you
want me to click here?
AUDIENCE: So go into
the movie.
COLT MCANLIS: He's going
to fix this.
I'm going to tell some great
stories about rasterization
real quick.
So for those of you who don't
know, who haven't been over to
the Chrome booth yet, we
actually have an entire area
there dedicated to
performance.
So a lot of you web developers
out here who are running into
problems with compute processes,
rendering issues,
or even network load times,
please come by
and stop by the booth.
Talk to us.
We've got pretty much all of
the genius brains of Google
who work on performance day and
night there waiting to ask
you questions, and to answer
your problems, and to run your
site through our tools,
and to solve all
sorts of critical things.
Still need more time?
Cool.
I can keep doing this.
All right, so for too long,
we've actually been spending a
lot of time talking about
network or web performance in
just terms of page wait.
So we're very concerned
about load time.
But as we've started getting
more web apps on mobile and
web apps doing crazy things, we
realized that the wait that
the user experiences your app
while they're inside of it
actually has a large--
GRACE KLOBA: We're back.
COLT MCANLIS: We're back?
Oh, well I was in the
middle of something.
Hold on.
Wait, no, I'm not done yet.
GRACE KLOBA: OK.
COLT MCANLIS: We realized that
how the user experiences your
app inside of it actually has
a lot to do with how much
money they're willing to spend
and how much you get from that
user in terms of retention.
So this means that we have to
start worrying about the other
factors too, things like compute
performance and render
performance, which brings us
back to how we can utilize the
GPU to get awesome stuff done.
Did I break it again?
Maybe it's my clicker.
There we go.
OK, so to rehash, after a five
minute soliloquy, we have this
duck effectively moving
to the screen.
It would be ideal if we
could effectively
know the context here.
Is that we have the duck
moving and we have the
background static.
It would great if we could
somehow separate these two
items so that the GPU can handle
positioning of the duck
and we won't have to use all
of the extra CPU cycles
painting the duck in position.
And this is actually what we
can do inside of Chrome.
We actually allow some
annotations and some
intrinsics that you can add to
your page that allow you to
separate page elements into
separate GPU layers.
What this means is that
effectively each layer has its
own set of tiles.
They're uploaded once
to the GPU.
And then the GPU can position
these things around without
any interaction in the CPU.
Of course, this turbo charges
the duck in their animation
allowing it to do awesome stuff
through the screen.
And it allows the CPU to sit
back and drink margaritas and
basically chill out
while the GPU does
all the heavy lifting.
Sorry, we're having fun
technical problems.
What kind of conference would
this be if you don't get a
blue screen while installing
printer software?
Anyhow, so this is how the
GPU stuff is working.
Now let's actually talk about
how you, as a developer, can
control all of these things.
First, it's worth pointing out
that there's a set of page
elements that are auto promoted
to their own layer
once your HTML is parsed and
your page is loaded.
Depending on your platform,
and your build, and your
hardware spec, things like
canvas, video, iframe, and
plug-ins are all promoted
to their own
layer on your behalf.
You don't have to do anything.
And this is fantastic because
most the time these type of
page elements spend their
entirety updating large
portions of the screen.
They could be overlapping
with other tiles.
Recall the animation
that you saw with
the duck moving around.
So we're spending lots of times
updating and rasterizing
pixels we don't actually
need to.
GRACE KLOBA: There is also a
set of the CSS properties
which will manually
promote the page
element to its own layer.
For example, all the 3D
Transform, like TranslateZ,
Translate3D.
This making sense because these
transforms can be easily
accelerated on the GPU.
It's worth noting the 2D
transform does not promote the
element to its own layer, which
means they will be still
rendered in the software mode.
COLT MCANLIS: Now those two
examples are effectively load
time modifications.
So effectively, you parse the
page elements, or you parse
the page, and these things are
auto promoted on your behalf.
It's worth pointing out that
there's a set of CSS
properties that allow you to
push things to a separate
layer at run time.
And the two tags you need to
be concerned with are CSS
animations for opacity
and transform.
How these effectively work is
that when the page loads, an
element on the page will stay
static with the base layer.
Once the animation begins, the
element in question will
actually be promoted
to its own layer.
So the CPU has to spin up,
create a new layer, paint the
data into the new layer, as
well as go back and paint
where the object used to
be in the base layer.
Then as the animation occurs,
the GPU and the CPU are
working in harmony creating
happy ducks through the
universe in a plethora of all
the quacks that you hear
through the cosmos.
And then at the end of the
animation, the duck then has
to be promoted back to the
base layer where it--
there we go.
Maybe it's my clicker.
The duck has to be demoted back
to the base layer, which
means we have to kill the
original layer we had and then
rerasterize the area where
the duck finally lands.
I'm just going to let you click
everything from now on.
Of course, this means
that we run into
some interesting concepts.
So if we start an animation and
all of a sudden we see a
hitch in our performance, this
means that the CPU may be
doing too much work and actually
firing up, doing
rasterization, and moving on.
Which means of course we have
to start talking about well,
why isn't everything in a
layer and what are the
consequences and tradeoffs
of doing that?
Well the first off thing is you
shouldn't put everything
in its own layer.
Even though the GPU can move
these things around and
position them, there's actually
some consequences you
should be aware of.
First off, is the cost
of too many layers.
You need to know that each layer
you put on the screen
effectively creates
more tiles.
And as Grace mentioned before,
the GPU has a static
non-growable memory resource
in its texture cache.
So what happens is as these
tiles are invalidated and more
tiles exist, if the cache is
full, we effectively have to
push old tiles out of the cache
before we can actually
put the new tiles in.
This is going to put a lot of
pressure on your cache, which
is going to result in more
evictions, which is going to
result in a lot of additional
CPU overhead painting new
tiles that would have previously
been resident
inside of the cache.
In addition to the tile
overhead, you also have to
take into account just
the additional
processing that's involved.
Now, this is minimal compared
to the cache thrashing.
But effectively, each layer that
you add has to be sorted
every frame.
There has to be occlusion
determinations that occur.
And then Chrome can actually
go through and do union
processing to determine whether
or not it should
actually draw something.
So let's say you have an object
and then you have an
opaque layer in front of it, we
may be actually able to not
draw that lower object because
it's actually hidden.
GRACE KLOBA: So there's
overhead, as Colt mentioned,
when the animation starts.
We pay extra cost to
promote the page
element to its own layer.
So if there is a lot of pixels
during the paint that may take
a longer time, which means
there's a long delay for the
animation to start.
So what you can do is, as we
earlier mentioned, the CSS
properties can permanently
move the page
element to its own layer.
So you can either translateZ(0)
to promote it in
the page loading time.
Of course, the tradeoff
is it's going to
use a lot of memory.
So now the job is--
it's your job to make the
decision whether you want
animation to start instantly
or you want to
preserve the memory.
Let's look at another example.
So on a mobile site, it's a
common case to try to slide in
some content from off
screen to on screen.
So for example, we have
this helpful duck.
When the page loaded, the
duck is off screen.
And then it has a display now.
So when the user asks the duck
for help and then what you
probably would do is change the
display property from none
to block and start
the animation.
Unfortunately, we cannot start
the animation right away
because we have to go
to paint the duck .
If this duck is fat, big, taking
a lot of pixels, it may
take a little bit longer time.
So what do we do?
Remember earlier, we mentioned
Chrome does pre-paint.
So if you keep that display
block property, even when the
duck is off the screen and also
use a previous trick we
mentioned, using the
translateZ(0) to permanently
promote it to its own layer,
after page loaded, before the
animation start, Chrome
will paint the
duck in its own layer.
So when user calls the duck for
help, the duck will just
jump out right away.
Of course, everything
there is a tradeoff.
If the user never calls the duck
for help, we still spend
cycles on the CPU to paint the
duck and then allocated memory
on the GPU to cache it.
COLT MCANLIS: So what basically
we're getting at
here is that with these small
annotations and these CSS
properties, you can actually
control how the GPU is being
used to render your page.
So you guys can make faster
loading websites, faster
rendering websites, which make
your users happier, which
means your websites
make more money.
And then your boss recognizes
your contribution and gives
you the bonus and promotion.
So really, we're here to help
you get promotions so you can
drink margaritas and stuff.
Now with that, that we're giving
to you, we're asking
you to then understand that as
we inject the GPU into the
process, some parts of the
architecture of how Chrome
works changes, which You
need to be aware of.
Most important of that
is how input is being
handled with this.
Because we're actually taking
what was a single-threaded
process and adding some new
components into it.
GRACE KLOBA: So before we talk
about this new [INAUDIBLE]
threaded compositing, let's take
a look at how without it
how it works.
So threaded compositing is a new
concept that we added into
the Chrome.
And the Chrome [INAUDIBLE]
working on Chrome for
Android, Chrome for
Chrome OS, and on Windows.
We're soon going to turn
it on the Mac.
So when something changed
[INAUDIBLE]
that's what do you did.
And then we will do the paint
and the composite
on the BLINK thread.
And then present this content
through the GPU commands to
the driver.
But the driver only consume
the GPU commands up to the
refresh rate.
For example, at a 60 FPS display
it only consume the
frame at 16.6 millisecond time
frame, which means there's no
need, in our case, even the
paint and to composite a small
amount of the work, there is
still no need to paint it
twice using a 16 milliseconds
frame.
COLT MCANLIS: And to be fair,
that diagram is actually a
little misleading.
The what's going on under the
hood in these browsers is not
actually that simple.
It's actually chaos in a jar,
what's really going on.
Effectively, if you look at
our single-threaded model
here, you have lots and lots
of resources and events
fighting for time slices on this
single-threaded model.
So things like parsing,
layout, paint,
all of these things.
So what happens is if we
actually get one of these
VBLANKS coming along asking for
updated data, there's a
good chance that with all
of the processing that's
occurring that the thread has
not actually had a chance to
paint and give the VBLANK an
updated vision of the scene.
Now, what's really interesting
about this, when you dig a
little bit deeper, is that
there's some things that you,
as a developer, can control.
So if we look at the breakdown
of the blocks here, things
like Touch Events, JavaScript
Events, onload callbacks, you
as developers really are in
control of how long those
events take on the JavaScript
processing thread.
Now, there's some other
things though that you
really can't control.
You can wave your hands at it
and maybe do some juju dances,
but it's really not going to
change because on the browser
side of things, that's
controlled--
things like layout, paints,
and compositing.
Now, the good thing is that some
of these can actually be
moved off onto different threads
because of modern
architectures.
Like most of the phones in your
pockets actually have
multiple cores, which means we
can utilize modern techniques
for threaded programming.
Now, there's a great technique
that Chrome does use called
multi-threaded painting, which
actually allows us to take the
paint block, which traditionally
was single
threaded sharing time with all
of your JavaScript events, and
actually thread that out off
to multiple threads, which
reduces the amount
of time it takes.
Now, we're not going to talk
about that today because
that's not on the GPU.
Instead, what we're going to
talk about today is this other
block here, which is actually
the composite operation.
The best way to think about this
is after your painting is
done, remember that Chrome has
to go back and actually create
all of these graphics driver
commands, GPU commands, to
take those textures and upload
them to the GPU and then
actually do that submit.
Of course, that isn't
actually free.
It actually cuts into
your frame time.
So what we want to talk about
today is how we move that off
onto a different thread and
what that means for you.
So we now have the BLINK thread,
which is effectively
responsible--
if there's one thing you should
all take away from this
today is that there are tons of
technical problems on this
side of the stage.
Basically we have our BLINK
thread, which handles all of
our JavaScript processing,
including layout and other
sorts of things.
And we can actually move the
composite operation down onto
a separate thread.
So this means that whenever the
system can define that a
composite is actually needed, we
can actually go through and
kick off a composite onto
a separate thread.
And one more.
GRACE KLOBA: One more.
OK.
COLT MCANLIS: There we go.
Too far.
No, go back.
The universe, you divided
by 0, no.
GRACE KLOBA: OK.
Calm down.
So it's good.
We move the composite into
a separate thread.
So we offload some work
from the BLINK thread.
But there is a key change we
made is let the composite
thread to accept input events
when it is possible.
For example, scroll events can
be received and processed on
the composite thread without
the intervention
of the BLINK thread.
This allows us to scroll as fast
as possible even there is
a long JavaScript is executing
in the BLINK thread.
It is the for this exactly
reason we ask you to let the
browser to scroll.
Simply put, if you're using
touch events or mousewheel
events to drive the scroll, the
benefit of the threaded
compositing is thrown
out of the window.
The custom scroll libraries
normally will put a touch
handler, mousewheel handler,
and then they will call
prevent default.
So the result is there's no
scroll events happen or get
sent to compositers thread.
What compositers thread can do
is just wait for the BLINK
thread to process the JavaScript
doing the layout
and then paint.
This is essentially go back to
the single thread [INAUDIBLE].
COLT MCANLIS: Now,
this is actually
pretty common on mobile.
So how many of you guys actually
have a mobile website
that has a static header
at the top of it?
A good amount of hands.
So OK, keep your hands up.
Keep your hands up.
How many of you, in order to
keep that banner at the top of
the page, actually intercept
the scroll handler?
Still a couple of you, OK.
Well, I'm here to let
you know that that's
actually a bad practice.
So just like Grace said, that
when you intercept the scroll
handler on Chrome for Android,
what you're effectively doing
is throwing out all of the
cool stuff you get from
multi-threaded compositing.
And the result of that is what
you're going to see is that as
the page scrolls, the scroll's
going to happen and the
headers going to move, whether
you like it or not.
And then your JavaScript
code is actually going
to execute and fire.
And then you'll see your header
snap to the position
that you want it to go to.
So if we have this beautiful
Duck Surfing 101 page here and
you have the page scroll, you
actually want this thing to
stay static.
Now, instead of actually
intercepting the scroll
handler, you can take advantage
of these CSS
properties that we've been using
and actually put the
header in its own layer.
So if you actually add a
position fixed as well as a
z-index 0 to this thing-- or
z-index anything really, just
as long as a z-index is there
so you can create proper
context stacking.
What this will do is actually
promote the header into its
own layer and allow the page
itself to transition
underneath it.
So you will get the overhead of
having your own layer, but
you won't get the ghost chasing
effect that you're
going to see on top of mobile.
If you want a really great
example of who does this
right, definitely check out
the Google I/O 2013 mobile
site where we do this on
the session agenda.
You can actually see as things
scroll, we have these static
headers at the top and it
does it the right way.
Look at the source code.
It's a great example.
And so with that though, it's
worth pointing out, that we
just gave you an example that
we didn't talk about before.
We talked about TranslateZ.
We talked about overflow.
We talked about those other
things and that will promote
items into their own
layer as well.
But in reality, you may have
inadvertently put something
into a layer without really
knowing about it, which means
that we are not leaving
you abandoned here.
We actually have updated our
tools to tell you how the GPU
is doing things.
First off, there's a fantastic
set of flags that you can turn
on in Chrome's dev tools
that will tell you
where the layers are.
First off, if you open up dev
tools you actually see this
beautiful awesome little flag
there that says, Show
Composited Borders.
What effectively this does is
any of your layers it will add
an orange border around the
boundaries of the layer.
So I randomly took a picture
of a random website on the
internet here.
And you can actually see that
what we have here is lots and
lots and lots of layers.
That's what each one of those
orange borders means.
So part of their feed here,
effectively, is each layer.
If you look at the source code
of this, you'll actually see
that each one of those leaf
elements in the DOM has
TranslateZ on it.
So once again, you're seeing
that this would come to bad
performance like we've
already talked about.
Because each one of those
layers is going to have
additional tiles.
All of those tiles are going to
be fighting for residency
inside of GPU memory.
And of course, this is going to
slow things down on mobile.
Now the cool thing is that it's
not always axial aligned
like one of the images there.
You can see that they actually
have this loading icon that is
going to be rotated with a CSS
transform as well as a little
animated gif too.
And you can see that the cool
borders match that as well.
Now, it's worth pointing out
that these borders, as they're
rendered, actually obey
occlusion ordering.
So effectively, if you've got
that nice little spinning
thing and then an image in
front of it, you won't
actually see that border.
So take that into account
as you're moving along.
Another great tool that you can
actually dive into is one
called chrome://tracing.
Now chrome://tracing
personally--
hey, I'm a beat box guy now.
Chrome://tracing is actually
my favorite tool inside of
Chrome because it will actually
tell you what Chrome
is doing under the hood.
Effectively, it gives you a
hierarchical view of the call
stack that's happening inside of
Chrome based upon what your
website is doing.
So I actually put together a
little test page to give you
this graphic here.
And effectively, all the test
page did was load a bunch of
large images, like 1024's and
2048's, and actually resize
them with a width and height
parameter down to 64 by 64's.
And this is what
chrome://tracing showed me.
So first off, the 1024 by
1024 actually took 51
milliseconds to decode.
And then after that,
it took another 29
milliseconds to resize.
So think of it this way, for
all of you guys in here who
are doing responsive web design,
and you're sending
your full resolution desktop
images down to your mobile
client because you feel that
that's the only way you can
handle viewport differences,
you could be
wasting a lot of time.
Instead, you can see that the
next image that I had in the
list was much smaller.
It was about 128 by 128.
So the decode took less
time, as well as the
resize took less time.
So the cool thing to take away
from this slide is that we can
actually figure out how your
page is using the GPU by
looking at some patterns that
you can see inside of
chrome://tracing.
GRACE KLOBA: So earlier we
talked about browser scroll
versus JavaScript scroll.
Let's take a look in the
chrome://tracing.
So in this case, the top row
is a compositers thread.
The bottom row called
[? CrRendererMain ?]
is essentially the
BLINK thread.
The number on the left is a
process ID because compositer
and the BLINK thread are both in
the render process, so they
have the same number,
same process ID.
Chrome trace also comes with
this nice FPS guideline.
So it's running at a 60 FPS,
repeated at 16.6 milliseconds.
In this case, [INAUDIBLE]
line data was the first
composite in this window.
As you can see, the scroll is
updated nicely at 60 FPS, even
when we have a long paint
happening in the BLINK thread.
Let's take look at
another trace.
This is done on the same device
with the same version
of the Chrome.
Instead, we load a different
page, of course.
Otherwise, it should be same.
So in this page, the JavaScript
is hijacking the
touch events, and then drive
the scrolling of the page.
First thing we did is pull back
our IPS guideline and
left the line with the
first composite.
Immediately, you will notice
between the second and the
third composite, it took 33
milliseconds instead of the 16
milliseconds.
Why?
Because in this case, we also
have a long paint happening in
the BLINK thread.
And because the scrolling is
driven by the JavaScript, so
the composite step in the
compositers thread cannot
start until the paint
is finished.
So again, the thing you want to
learn from this example is
let the browser scroll.
COLT MCANLIS: And with that, we
can recap what we've talked
about today.
Four main bullet points to
walk away from this talk.
Number one, making a
presentation is a lot more
technically difficult apparently
than writing a
whole web browser.
First off is actually
GPU plus layers
equals faster rendering.
By actually getting the GPU
into the mix and actually
using layers, we can allow it
to alleviate a lot of the
processing burden that would
previously exist in
rasterization on the CPU.
But that comes with a caveat
though, is that too many
layers is going to be a
seriously bad time.
If you put too many layers out
there, everything's going to
be fighting for residency inside
of the GPU tile cache
and that's going to create
some problems.
In addition to that, that's
going to create some changes
in how input is handled,
especially for mobile devices,
which means that you guys
should really let Chrome
handle the scrolling
of things.
You're going to have a
smoother frame rate.
It's going to give your
users a better
impression of your site.
You're going to make lots of
money and get really cool
promotions.
And then you can send Grace and
I emails thanking us for
all of our time and effort
that we put into this
technically flawed talk.
And then finally, if you're not
really sure what's going
on, please use tooling to
verify what's going
on under the hood.
Use things like show composited
borders, as well as
about tracing and get
a really good deep
dive of what's happening.
So with that, we thank you all
so much for giving us your
time today.
Before we take off, I want
to actually, once again,
encourage all of you to use the
perfmatters hashtag for
any of your web performance
related things.
As well as invite you
to join the Google+
web performance community.
You can see the short link
there goo.gl/webperf.
It's a fantastic community.
We've got lots of the big brains
in web performance all
contributing there.
It's a community of awesome
web performance stuff.
With that, it looks like we've
got about four minutes and 30
seconds for questions.
The mics are here.
Please give us your thoughts.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I have three brief
questions if I can read my own
handwriting.
COLT MCANLIS: Wait, how
brief can they be?
You wrote them down.
AUDIENCE: That was so I
could pay attention.
COLT MCANLIS: That's not
a brief question.
AUDIENCE: What is the limit
to the number of tiles?
Is it 100 tiles, 1,000 tiles,
10 tiles, in the mem
cache of the GPU?
GRACE KLOBA: It really
depends.
As we mentioned, the impact
of the tiles is memory.
So we try to do--
[? the parsing ?]
is the tile is fully behind
it, we're not
going to render it.
But if there is overlap because
of the tile size, you
of course pay the overhead.
So that depends on how
much you overlap.
AUDIENCE: So I guess the main
question is, how big is the
memory that's allocated
to the GPU?
GRACE KLOBA: As I think I
mentioned earlier, it's really
device dependent.
So for example, [INAUDIBLE]
the Android mobile device,
we're basically using the
memory limit, which is--
most of today's mobile devices
are unified memory.
So the total memory on the
Galaxy Nexus is 1 gig, on the
Nexus 10 it's 2 gig.
That's overall memory.
But available for the GPU we use
that one as a measurement
and also using the screen
resolution as a measurement.
In these two cases, we probably
allocated a limited,
so around 256 meg.
AUDIENCE: OK, so it's actually
part of the RAM is--
GRACE KLOBA: Yeah,
part of the RAM.
And then we have to be
conservative because there's
other apps.
So we basically allocate a
budget based on the device
memory limit and the
screen resolution.
AUDIENCE: OK, should I go to the
back of the line or ask--
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah,
if you don't mind.
We'll get some more
questions in here.
This side over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, question is, are
there any good methods for
syncing scrolling between
different panes, if you want
to create a paned approach, that
don't rely on JavaScript?
GRACE KLOBA: Different page?
AUDIENCE: Panes.
So for example, your
iOS session
example was a good one.
I noticed on iOS on Safari
that while the vertical
scrolling sticks nicely, the
horizontal scrolling doesn't
work at all.
It doesn't keep it in
sync as you scroll.
So are there mechanisms to have
different divs within a
web page where the scrolling in
one direction or the other
is synced between them, and yet,
still have some of the
advantages of layering?
GRACE KLOBA: I think, if I
understand the question, is
you want the vertical scroll
handled by the browser, but
the left and the right
handled by content?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, think of Google
spreadsheet where you
have the ability to split panes
and go both directions.
Well, when I scroll horizontally
I need both the
header, or top and bottom
panes, to stay in sync.
COLT MCANLIS: I think the--
AUDIENCE: When I scroll
vertically I need--
COLT MCANLIS: You have
to invoke dark magic.
That's a tricky one.
Let's dig deep on that if
you guys wouldn't mind.
We're actually running
out of time here.
And I know there's lots of
question, so Grace and I will
actually be at the Chrome
Office Hours for
the next half hour.
Please, everyone in line and
anyone else who has questions,
please come meet us there.
Let's talk more about this stuff
and help you guys out.
Once again, thank you
for your time today.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]